[Musique]
mettons à l'honneur la nature voilà la
thématique de la 17e édition de la Fête
de la nature organisée par le
département qui s'est tenu du 24 au 28
mai dernier 5 jours 120 visites guidées
et 35 sites naturels à découvrir dont
des nouveautés cette année comme
lillette quinquina ou les Réunionnais
étaient invités à en apprendre plus sur
la faune aquatique et la réglementation
de la pêche ici dans les hauteurs de
Saint-Denis les partenaires à savoir EDF
la Fédération de Pêche le parc national
et l'office de l'eau se sont mobilisés
pour proposer différents ateliers avec
l'objectif de sensibiliser les visiteurs
à la protection des milieux naturels
pour pouvoir récupérer des espèces ou à
montrer au public dans les petits
aquariums aujourd'hui et si je suis
arrivé depuis comme l'ensemble des cours
d'eau qu'on a à la Réunion on peut
retrouver
l'ensemble des espèces plaisantes à
l'espèce indigènes telles que l'on dit
les trois espèces d'Andy les caves aux
bûcherons les crustacés
du poisson plat donc jusqu'à on peut
arriver jusqu'à 17 espèces indigènes en
fait sur le coup à deux la vipicole ici
je suis à nos Codo en fait elle est pour
certaines espèces en net diminution des
vraiment de quoi doit protéger avec des
espèces vraiment de plus en plus
pendant ce temps dans l'Est à
Saint-André la visite guidée du petit
étang a déjà commencé le temps d'une
matinée petits et grands ont parcouru
les berges de cette étang côtier au
programme découverte durée sans chantier
de restauration écologique du site de sa
biodiversité remarquable et des dangers
du braconnage sur le milieu aquatique
qui réalise de la protection milieu
aquatique et puis et puis la mise en
exactivité pêche et le département
finance tout un programme de
restauration écologique qui entrent dans
nos statuts donc on a une zone humide
petite étang qui plus à cet André une un
petit état naturel qui était en train de
s'atrophier qui est en train de mourir à
petit feu et donc on a mis en oeuvre pas
mal d'actions beaucoup d'actions même
pour
retisionner le petit étangs enlever les
plantes qui étaient envahir la surface
et restaurer des BH avec des
représentation des personnes endémiques
des plantes durant la Fête de la Nature
sur le site on reçoit le grand public et
on a
au coin de l'année plusieurs visites de
plusieurs acteurs qui viennent profiter
de l'espace une escapade qui s'est
achevée par la plantation d'espèces
endémiques par les visiteurs séduit par
la démarche j'ai vu la Fête de la nature
comme je marche pas mal et ça
m'intéressait quoi moi dans ma tête je
venais pour faire une marche autour du
petit étang et c'est pas du tout ça
c'est une bonne découverte je sais qu'il
y a beaucoup de fun et de flore quand
même à la Réunion mais pas Saint-André
sur ce petit étang et puis ben on se
rend compte de tout ce que fait les
associations quoi faire connaître et
valoriser le travail des gestionnaires
de sites qui travaillent toute l'année
sur les espaces naturels de l'île cela
fait justement partie des objectifs de
cette Fête de la Nature l'occasion aussi
de favoriser des comportements plus
responsables et respectueux du
patrimoine naturel de la Réunion
[Musique]